[MUSIC PLAYING]
GREG MOORE: Hello Googlers,
both here in Sunnyvale
and around the world.
Good afternoon.
My name is Greg Moore.
I lead health care
here at Google Cloud.
And we have a very, very special
guest with us this afternoon.
It gives me great pleasure
to introduce to you
today Dr. Lloyd B. Minor, M.D.
Dr. Minor is the Carl
and Elizabeth Naumann
Dean of the Stanford
University School of Medicine.
Under his leadership Dr.
Minor has established
and is now executing
strategic vision
to lead a biomedical revolution
both nationally and globally
in precision health.
Dr. Minor is a professor of
otolaryngology, head and neck
surgery, at Stanford University
with additional appointments
both in bioengineering
and neurobiology.
He's a prolific author.
Over 140 published
papers and chapters,
a widely-recognized authority
in the area of balance
and inner ear disorders.
For his contributions
in 2012 Dr. Minor
was elected to the National
Academy of Medicine.
So we're really pleased to have
Dr. Minor with us here today.
Let's give him a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
LLOYD B. MINOR: Thanks a lot.
Well, thank you, Greg.
It's really a privilege and
an honor to be here today.
And as I was thinking
about my remarks,
Google is about to celebrate
its 20th anniversary.
We-- Stanford and Google--
obviously share
a lot of history.
Right?
I mean, Google began in
two dorm rooms at Stanford.
And early on the
founders articulated
what principles that
they described as,
10 things we know to be true.
So I thought I would
parallel that a bit.
And I think you're
going to recognize
some distinct similarities
between 10 things
that I know to be true
about health and health care
and what the founders had in
mind in establishing Google,
and what is very much reflected
today in the great work
that all of you are doing.
So, principle number one.
Very similar to principle
number one for Google.
For Google, of course, focus
on the user and all else
will follow.
For us in health
and health care,
focus on the patient and
all else will follow.
And this may seem
to be self-evident,
but it's actually
only recently that I
think health care professionals
have begun to embrace
this as the True North.
Only recently because,
unlike managing our finances
or deciding what car
we're going to buy
or what bicycle
or what school we're
going to send our kids to,
health and health
care in the past
has not always garnered
the degree of engagement
from consumers that almost
every other aspect of life has.
All too common there's been the
attitude, well if I get sick
I'll go to the doctor
and they'll fix me.
Or I'll take a medicine
and it will cure me.
And so the notion that--
I think there are lots
of reasons for that.
But I think one reason is
that we, as health care
professionals, haven't
focused on involving
our patients, the people who
entrust us with their care
and who look to
us to be advisors
as well as to bring our
expertise to their treatment--
we haven't always
focused on the way
that we can engage patients
in the way we need to.
And yet, really, if you
go back to the founding
of modern medicine and some of
the original greats who helped
get us started on a more
scientific path in medicine--
you know, William Osler, who
was the first physician in chief
at Johns Hopkins Hospital--
sort of a founder of
modern internal medicine--
he famously said, you know,
listen to your patients.
They're trying to tell
you their diagnosis.
And so today this principle of,
focus on the patient and all
else will follow,
has never, ever
been more applicable
than it is today.
And what I'll talk about a
bit more, and what many of you
are engaged in every day,
is that our opportunity
to use technology to
focus on our patient,
to use technology for high tech
to enable high touch health
care has never been
greater than it is today,
and is going to continue
to increase exponentially
in the weeks, months,
and years ahead.
So second principle.
The future of health
care is proactive.
Related to the first,
what I just spoke about,
in the past we've
tended to think,
well, if we get sick
we go and we get fixed.
We either have an operation,
we take a medication.
We've had far less attention
on how we can prevent disease
in the first place, how we
can be much more proactive--
us as individuals
thinking about our health,
and health care
professionals thinking
about how we develop the
science around prediction
and prevention.
And as Greg mentioned
before, we've
had a strategic vision
at Stanford Medicine
on focusing on what we
call precision health.
Now, all of you have heard
of precision medicine.
And we for sure practice
precision medicine at Stanford.
Precision medicine is about
using genomics and informatics
to improve the care we deliver
to patients with cancer,
so that the care is
truly personalized,
individualized, based upon
the molecular and genetic
characteristics of the tumor.
And for sure when we have
cancer or heart disease
we need precision medicine.
But wouldn't it be great if
we prevented those conditions
to begin with, or
if we diagnosed them
much earlier than we did today.
So the way we think
about the difference
is that precision medicine
is about sick care.
Precision health is
about health care.
The goal of precision
health is to predict,
to prevent, and cure precisely.
But really in that order.
Prediction, prevention,
and then cure when we still
are not able to
adequately prevent
a disease from occurring
in the first place.
And we're seeing all sorts of
examples where that vision is
coming into reality today.
And of course the way we
will know 10 years from now
that we've succeeded
in this vision
is that the need for
precision medicine, the need
for the ultra-complex
acute care will
be reduced because we will
have prevented or diagnosed
early and therefore more
effectively treated diseases
before they need the complex
tertiary and quaternary care.
Principle number three.
Data holds the secret
to better health.
There's a tremendous amount of
health data that exists today
embedded with electronic
medical records,
coming in from wearables.
So when I think
about digital health
I think about two related but
somewhat distinct verticals.
One vertical focused on
consumer-facing devices,
the things that enable us to
get a lot more information
about how our body is working.
And then the other
closely-related but distinct
area is the analytics
related to complex data sets.
So how do we bring in data from
those consumer-facing devices
combined with the
data that's sitting,
by and large, unaddressed in
electronic medical records
today in order to inform
decision-making and engage
people more in their health
and their health care.
There's tremendous
opportunity in both areas,
both in terms of consumer-facing
devices and technologies
and also in analytics.
Let me just give
you one example.
You know, earlier in my career--
as Greg mentioned,
I'm an ear expert.
I focused on inner
ear balance disorders
and in 1998 I described a
clinical syndrome, an inner ear
disorder.
It's a disorder with
one of the balance
canals of the inner ear.
It's a disorder caused
by the bone that
should cover that balance
canal getting eroded over time,
and then the balance canal
itself begins to respond
to sound and pressure.
So these patients that
have this disorder
experience certain very
distinct recognizable symptoms
and signs.
And one of those is that they
have noise-induced dizziness.
And so if you open the Google
search engine right now
and you type "noise
dizziness," on the first page
you'll get several websites
that describe this syndrome,
superior canal
dehiscence syndrome,
as well as a host
of other conditions
that can cause related
symptoms and signs.
If you type those same two
words in the chief complaint
line of one of the commonly-used
electronic medical records
systems today in doctors
offices and hospitals
around the country,
you get, as a provider,
no diagnostic assistance at all.
So if you're someone
in my specialty,
you've certainly seen patients
with the disorder before.
You know to be suspicious.
But if you're a primary
care physician who's
may be seeing a patient
with this disorder
for the first time, you may not
know that that's the diagnosis.
And so it's still
the most common way
that patients with this disorder
are being diagnosed today,
is by searching the symptoms and
the signs themselves, usually
on Google, and finding a website
that describes the condition,
and then going to their
physician and saying,
I think I have this.
Look at this web page.
We can do better than that.
We can do a lot
better than that.
And I think the work that's
going on in Google Cloud as
well as a lot of
different other areas,
is going to get us more towards
the type of environment that
can really enable us to fulfill
this vision of precision
health.
Fourth principle.
To change health, we
have to change behavior.
You know, when we look at
the determinants of health,
of wellness and well-being--
yes, there is medical
care and there's genomics.
But if we look at health and
well-being as being a pie,
then genomics and medical
care represent maybe 25%
to 30% of that pie.
The majority of the
determinants of health
are behavioral, social,
and environmental factors.
And yet in the past we
focused far less attention--
and by "we" I hold ourselves
in academic medicine very much
accountable for this--
we focused far less
attention on behavior
and social and
environmental factors
than we have on the medical
and genomic factors.
And today we obviously have
the opportunity to change that.
Now, let me mention
one project and I'm
really excited about
going on today,
started by a team of
Stanford investigators.
It goes by the acronym SPHERE.
So at Stanford,
just as at Google,
acronyms play a big role
in how we communicate.
SPHERE is short for
Stanford Precision Health
for Ethnic and Racial Equity.
And one of the projects
sponsored by-- this
is funded by an NIH grant.
One of the projects
sponsored by this grant
looks at obesity in
latino-american children,
focusing initially in
Santa Clara County.
So over 200 children
and their families
right now in Santa Clara
County enrolled in this study.
And yes, we are looking at their
genomics, at their microbiome,
at other metabolic parameters.
But we're also
looking at what types
of interventions such
as changing the size
of the plates in the home.
Rather than giving large
plates, furnishing the family
with smaller plates.
How can exercise and
physical activity
be encouraged either in the
school environment, the home
environment, or getting
to and from school?
So both an approach
that looks at, yes,
what are the traditional
medical genomic factors that
are involved in
obesity, but also
looking at the
social, environmental,
and behavioral factors.
And it's through that
combination, really looking
at the whole pie of
health and well-being,
that we're going
to be much better
able to have an impact
with the people who
entrust their care
to us, have an impact
on health and well-being.
You don't need to be at
a hospital to get care.
I think that's obvious
today, but it's
going to become more
obvious in the future.
We rolled out a
program to people
who were enrolled in
our accountable care
organization, Stanford
Health Care Alliance,
called Click Well.
Click Well lets you do
fairly common, simple things,
like schedule an
appointment online.
But it also allows you to
schedule a telemedicine visit
with a health care provider
or with a lifestyle
coach or a nutritionist.
And what better way to
talk with a nutritionist,
rather than coming
into an office
and sitting across a
desk from a nutritionist,
why not have that interaction in
your kitchen, with your spouse
or significant other,
and talk in real time
about meal planning and
cooking and nutrition?
So we're just scratching
the surface today
of the possibilities of
telemedicine and also
of how people are able to engage
with the health care delivery
system in ways other
than physically being
in an office or a hospital.
But in the end part of
this greater accountability
and engagement of people
in health and well-being
involves making it more
accessible and, if you will,
easier for each of us to
learn about our health
and be more proactively
engaged in our health
than the old model
where we would go in
and see our doctor once a
year, get some lab tests done,
and then forget about
everything in between.
Number six, fundamental
discovery pays off.
You know, it's fascinating to
think that the transistor was
only developed in 1947.
Right?
And when John
Bardeen developed it,
it was considered
a lab curiosity.
I mean, how could he
or his contemporaries
have imagined what was
going to result just
in a couple of generations.
Right?
And also we know that
GPS was developed
as a variant on an
atomic clock to test
Einstein's theory of
relativity, and look
how GPS is being used today.
So we never really,
at the outset,
know where a fundamental
discovery is going to go,
but I've yet to see a
fundamental discovery that
hasn't had some profound impact.
An example from our own world--
we're today very fortunate.
The School of Medicine
have seven Nobel laureates
on our faculty.
One of those, Michael
Levitt, won the Nobel Prize
in chemistry a few
years ago for work
that he did more
than 20 years ago.
Michael was really one of the
first computational structural
biologists.
He used computer
programs and algorithms
to predict how the
structure of proteins
change in different conditions.
Those formative
algorithms, the approach
that he took in his very
original and creative work,
are now in use today
in drug companies
to allow them to
predict how changing
the structure of a drug
will alter its interactions
with the receptor.
So an entire field
of drug discovery
was born based upon some very
fundamental computational work
designed to understand
the structure of proteins.
Number seven, one that we're
very pleased to collaborate
and embrace with you.
Academia and industry
must collaborate.
It's always been true.
If we look at, for example,
one of the great success
stories of the past
20 years in medicine,
and that is changing HIV from
being a 100% fatal diagnosis
now to being, in the
vast majority of cases,
a successfully chronic disease--
successfully managed on
multiple antiviral therapy.
That success story required
discovery-based research
at universities.
It required clinical
trials at universities,
but would not have occurred
without the type of support
and the type of
focus and resources
that pharma brings
to problems as well.
And the same is going to be true
in the digital world, for sure.
And I'm really pleased that
we collaborate with Greg
and team at Stanford
in using Google
Cloud for our genomics
platform and the analytics
that you have
developed here, and
pleased that in another
branch of Alphabet, Verily,
we're working on what we call
the Google baseline study, left
over from when
Verily was Google.
So baseline is a 10,000-person
longitudinal cohort study.
Cohort, in that it's 10,000
people and everything
you and I can imagine about
their health will be measured.
Whole genome sequencing,
immunome, microbiome.
Verily developed a new wearable
to track these enrollees
over a long period of time,
initially at least four years.
And for the first time we'll
have enough baseline data
about the health of
these individuals
to be able to look
back and to say, well,
when someone develops a
disease later on, well,
here were the early indicators.
Rarely do we have that
sort of information today.
So some of the patients
enrolled in baseline
are going to be healthy today.
Some will have a diagnosis
of cancer already,
and some already a
diagnosis of heart disease.
And the information gathered in
this fashion very much powered
by the type of analytics
that you and your colleagues
do every day is going to give
us insights we've never ever
had before in health
and health care.
Number eight.
Diversity drives innovation.
In academia and in industry
there's a lot of thought about,
well, do you need
specialists or generalists?
And of course you
need some specialists
and some generalists.
But often times
the real advances
come from what are described
as T-shaped people.
That is, people who are
specialists in an area
but also who have a broad
horizontal component cutting
across multiple different areas.
I know you have many such
people here at Google.
So there's that sort of
diversity in terms of diversity
of ability and
thought, but also--
and in particular in
health and health care--
we have to focus more on
ethnic, racial, socioeconomic
diversity.
Over half the children
under the age of five
in the United States
today are from what
previously were
considered to be minority
racial and ethnic groups.
And the majority of
the US population
will be that
minority coming ahead
in the next 40 to 50 years.
And yet today only about 5.5%
of the physicians in the United
States identify themselves
as African-American,
and only about 6.3% identify
themselves as Hispanic.
We have to do better in
terms of representation
in our profession.
It's been a big passion
of mine since coming
to Stanford five years ago.
I'm pleased that in our
medical school class
we've moved from
five years ago having
14% from under-represented
groups to now having 26%
entering our medical school.
And in our biosciences
PhD program
we've moved from 12% from
under-represented groups
five years ago now to 25%.
But we can't take our
eye off that ball.
We can't for a moment back
away from our commitment
to achieving greater
diversity in our profession,
and I think it applies certainly
across the board in professions
in the country today.
Well, one that's familiar and
took me a while to get used to,
and that is, you can be
serious without a suit.
There's the obvious
implication of this.
And I'll tell you a funny story.
When I was looking at this
job and I was making trips
out from the East
Coast-- and, of course,
searches of this nature
are done pretty quietly
because of factors
at the institution
you're moving to and factors
where you're coming from.
So I was coming
out on a Saturday
and I got a call from the
office organizing the search.
And they said, you know,
you're meeting with the search
committee on
Saturday, and the men
will not be wearing a necktie.
And I went home that
evening and said to my wife,
I got this call and they
said that the guys coming
on Saturday won't be
wearing a necktie,
and I think that means I'm not
supposed to wear a necktie.
And she said, yeah,
you know, that's
definitely what it means.
And that's going
to be hard for you
because you wear
a necktie when you
take a shower in the morning.
So I have gotten used to
not wearing a necktie.
I think the more serious
side of this statement
is that we shouldn't be taking
ourselves too seriously.
You know, the beginning of
a decline of an organization
usually centers around two
things, complacency and hubris.
And in particular in
health care we for sure
can't be complacent.
And in the past, I think--
and I would say the physician
profession in particular
has had more than
its share of hubris.
And that has to
change moving forward.
Before medicine became more
scientifically-grounded,
what physicians offered their
patients was an ear, a shoulder
to rest a head on,
an understanding,
empathetic voice.
But there wasn't all
that much that physicians
could bring to the table.
That's changed
today, fortunately,
and we wouldn't want to go back.
But that desire and
that need for empathy
has never been greater
than it is today.
I mentioned before
that we started this--
that in our accountable
care organization
we allow people to
have virtual visits.
And that's great, and many
people take advantage of them.
We also give people
the option of receiving
all of their health care
virtually, if they wish.
And almost no one
elects to have that.
They want to have a primary
care provider who knows them,
who they rely upon as a
primary care provider.
But they understand
that that person may not
be available at 8
o'clock at night
when they have a question.
And that really then
gets back to the crux
of the talk and the discussion.
And that is, how
can high tech be
better able to enable
the high touch that I
think everyone expects from us?
So that's on the part about
making sure there's no hubris.
But then the part
about complacency
and how it can spell the
downturn of any organization
really relates to
principle number 10,
exactly the same as Google's
principle number 10.
Great just isn't good enough.
And certainly when we're talking
about health and well-being,
when we have this crying need
in the United States today--
you know 18% of our GDP
being spent on health care,
and yet our outcomes
are very poor compared
to other OECD countries.
You know, we have to be doing
better than we're doing today,
and I think we always
have to embrace the notion
and live the notion that
great isn't good enough.
Thank you very much.
I'd certainly welcome
your questions.
I'm honored to be here today.
[APPLAUSE]
GREG MOORE: Thank you so much,
Lloyd, for that inspiring talk.
Happy to take questions here.
And because I have
the microphone
I get to ask the first one,
and then we'll come over.
So many of the
engineers here at Google
are engaged in machine learning.
That's the engine.
The fuel for that
engine is data.
Your point number
three, that data does
hold secrets, as
you said-- secrets
that can help us help
patients globally,
and to unlock those secrets
for discovery and for research.
How can the academic medical
centers, one of which you run,
and the industry collaborate
to begin to use that data more
effectively?
Because it's always
been a friction point
and there's
consequences to delay
of sharing that data, of course,
that impact the patients.
LLOYD B. MINOR: Sure.
I think the data sharing
problem has several root causes.
There are increasingly
areas of care
that are covered by
bundled payments.
Namely, that the health system,
the physician-- everyone
gets paid a fixed amount
and not anything more.
But still, by and large, it's
a fee-for-service backbone.
And therefore it
hasn't necessarily
been perceived to be to the
advantage of health care
delivery systems to make
data easily portable.
That's one reason.
Second is, there is
the legitimate concern
about the privacy
and security of data.
And it's a real concern that--
I've read that it's estimated
that about 42% of Americans
have had, in some way, their
health records breached.
But, you know,
that's not all that
difficult to see how that
happens, and you would know
better than I. But
when you have data
in multiple different
platforms sitting in servers
all over the place managed
with various different security
regimens, that's
kind of a recipe--
isn't it-- for
having data breached.
So I think one thing that
you do, obviously-- and you
do really, really well-- is to
manage the security of data.
I mean, it is your
entire business.
And I know you have
lots and lots of people
working on that every day.
So I think that what you
bring to the table, obviously,
analytics and data
security, most people--
when they trust that their
privacy will be protected--
are happy to share at least
portions of their health record
for the greater
benefit of discovery
and for the greater
benefit of care
even though it may not
immediately benefit them.
But I think we haven't had
the incentives in the system
to communicate that, nor have
we had the portals to enable
people to elect to
bring their data in,
or for organizations like
yours to be able to aggregate
the data in a sufficiently
meaningful way that truly
leverages the power of big data.
When I talk to my computer
science colleagues
and I say that we have over
2 million unique patients
in the Stanford medical record--
and we do have a de-identified
version of that record--
their comment is, oh,
that's not big data.
You know?
Call us again when
you have 20 million.
If you have 200 million--
yeah.
Then we would be interested.
So we have to figure out ways
to aggregate data together,
for sure, to increase
the security of data,
and then to convey
the benefits of being
able to study the
data in the way
that we're capable of doing.
GREG MOORE: Thank you.
I think we had a question here?
And I'll ask you to come
back and use the microphone,
if you don't mind.
For those remote.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My question is that, related
to the technological advances
like machine
learning, there might
be a move towards diagnosing
patients through technology?
Do you see that as
something that's actually
going to develop
in the near future,
maybe with diagnostic
applications replacing doctors?
Or do you see technology
more as augmenting
the power of doctors?
LLOYD B. MINOR: I
think it initially
will be augmenting
the power of doctors.
And already an interpretation
of radiology, imaging studies,
we're seeing the
tremendous power
of augmenting the diagnosis
and of using machine
learning initially on an
imaging study to give a reading,
and then having that confirmed
or not by radiologists.
You know, I don't think
that the need for--
I think the role of physicians
is going to change for sure.
And there may be some
specialties more affected
by those changes than others.
But the need to have a human
interface in health care
I don't think is going away
any time in my lifetime.
I certainly think the
majority of physicians
welcome the opportunity to
more constructively engage
technology.
You know, one of
the problems today
is that electronic medical
records are oftentimes
cited as a or the
leading contributor
to physician burnout in America.
So over 50% of physicians
in America today,
by a variety of
different metrics,
are determined to be burned out.
Now that is really,
really concerning.
And as an organization
that trains physicians,
it's enormously
concerning to me.
And an average
primary care physician
is spending two additional
hours a day doing documentation
in the electronic
medical record at home
or after hours in
addition to the care
that she or he is
providing to patients.
And furthermore, during their
encounters with patients
they may be at a
terminal typing,
not looking someone in
the eye, and really trying
to have an empathetic
conversation with them.
So in that sense
technology gets a bad rap.
That's not really-- the
bad rap is on the structure
of the systems.
And there are a whole
host of reasons for that.
It's not technology per se.
So I embrace what
is occurring today
in health-related
technology and what
I know is going to occur
even more in the future.
GREG MOORE: Thank you.
I think we're going to take a
question remotely from Dory.
The highest voted one
is at the top there.
"Medical technology improvements
are great but often come
with a very high price tag.
We are increasingly faced
with health care occupying
a greater proportion of GDP.
How can a health care
system like Stanford
deliver precision in a
cost-effective manner that
is accessible to the populous?"
LLOYD B. MINOR: Right.
It's certainly true that most
technologies, particularly when
they're first
introduced, increase
the cost of health care.
It's not true across
the board though.
Let me give you
a counter-example
that I think
increasingly will be
paradigmatic for the
type of cost efficiencies
that can occur with
advances in technology.
You know, it used to
be that the only way
to diagnose a chromosomal
abnormality in a fetus
was with a procedure
called amniocentesis.
That's inserting a
needle through the skin
of the abdomen in the mom and
withdrawing amniotic fluid
and then looking and doing
a chromosome analysis
from the amniotic fluid.
It's an invasive procedure.
It carries a risk to
the fetus, and it's
an expensive procedure.
And fortunately
it's now virtually
been eliminated
because it was found
that you can as
accurately diagnose
a fetal chromosomal abnormality
from the circulating DNA
in a blood test from
the mom as you can
from withdrawing amniotic fluid.
So now a simple
blood test can be
used to diagnose
chromosomal abnormalities.
That's a tremendous savings
in terms of the dollar sign,
but even more importantly in
terms of reducing the risk.
And there are going to be
a host of other advances
under that umbrella.
But a lot of the problem--
a lot of the reason, I think,
for medical technology driving
up costs is that
we, by and large,
introduced medical technology
in the most severe, complex
diseases.
And as we start seeing
technology transform
in the areas of prediction
and prevention technology
should actually be
driving down cost.
And there are examples of that
today, examples of companies,
for example, in
diabetes management.
By measuring glucose--
either continuous monitoring
or intermittent
monitoring-- and then
having coaches that receive
the information as well
as the individual,
the management
of diabetes in a lot of people
is being dramatically improved.
The savings in terms of cost
of health care in those people
with diabetes far outstrips
the cost of the implementation
of the technology.
So it's both a problem that
the technology has been focused
on the most severe, acute
and chronic diseases,
and the technology has not made
its way into the prediction
and prevention realm in the
way I think it will very soon.
GREG MOORE: Thank you.
A question back here, locally?
AUDIENCE: Just a question
on changing health care
from reactive to proactive
using precision health.
So, like precision
medicine, things
like genome-wide
association studies
are great for diagnosing
metabolic pathways.
But how do we change those
things into actionable things
physicians can do?
So, for an example, if I find
LDL cholesterol is associated
with aortic stenosis, do I start
prescribing statins right away
to a person who has
LDL high cholesterol?
Right?
So it seems almost invasive
to start becoming proactive.
LLOYD B. MINOR: Yeah.
Well, let me mention an example
similar to the one you just
very nicely described
where already we're
seeing an analytical
approach making a difference.
You know, congestive
heart failure--
heart failure is one of the
most common causes of people
being admitted to the hospital.
And now in Medicare, for
patients with heart failure
who are covered by Medicare, if
you're admitted to the hospital
and then you go home and you
get readmitted within 30 days,
the hospital gets paid very
little for that readmission.
So what we need to
do is figure out
what are the parameters of
the management of that patient
to know that they're
optimized before they go home
and that they won't be coming
back into the hospital.
And using an approach that
I'm certain is similar to what
you're doing every day
in your work, Nigam Shah,
a professor at Stanford,
was able to look at multiple
different factors-- almost
like a [INAUDIBLE] study
for physiological parameters--
and identify in a
weighted fashion
what the predictors
of remission would be.
And that algorithm can
now be implemented,
used in real-time as
physicians are making
the rounds in the
morning, to say,
well, Mr. Jones looks like
the probability of readmission
is less than 10%.
He's feeling well.
He's ready to go home.
Or, no, he's still got these
indicators that would--
or these parameters that
would indicate there's
a very high probability
of readmission.
So for that to be successful
required aggregation
of a lot of data, and
then machine learning,
and then testing the
algorithms to see
if they're accurately predicting
the probability of readmission.
That model will certainly
generalize to other diseases
and conditions, including the
one that you just mentioned
on cholesterol management.
GREG MOORE: Thank you.
Another one here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for your lecture.
My question is about precision
health and preventive
health and nutrition.
Nutritional studies
are notoriously
difficult to conduct,
and I'm just curious
about your thoughts on how
nutritional studies could
be better designed and funded--
high-quality studies--
funded until we have
the benefits of that knowledge.
Thanks.
LLOYD B. MINOR: I think, to take
the second part of the question
first, as we move more away
from a fee-for-service model
and more into a model that
places risk and accountability
for health on the shoulders
of health care providers
and systems as well as on
the shoulders of consumers
receiving health care,
then it will be a much more
appealing business
model to really focus in
on nutrition and other
factors that can play
into keeping a person healthy.
So the reason that
there hasn't been--
there are many reasons.
And you're right, it is
difficult to study what we're
eating and then sort that
out among the many variables
that impact health.
But there haven't been the
incentives to focus on those
types of studies as there
have been, for example,
to focus on new classes of drugs
for you-name-the-condition.
Now, it shouldn't be
an either/or world.
I mean, we shouldn't abandon
the amazing work that's
going on today, for example,
in cancer immunotherapy,
which is truly transformative.
So it is precision
devoted at the cure,
a part of the equation
of precision health.
But there will be more
and more economic emphasis
on understanding the
roles of nutrition
as it becomes an economic
imperative for health care
delivery systems
to be engaged more
in thinking about
maintaining health
of those who are enrolled
in their benefits and health
plans.
So I think that's one element.
The other-- most
people employed today
are being employed
by organizations
that, in one form or
another, are self-insured.
So there's a lot that
companies and organizations
can do in the type
of food they offer
in cafeterias, in the type
of nutritional education
that's offered as a part
of being an employee.
There's a lot that can be
done right at the workplace
even before the health
care delivery systems start
embracing it into
the models of care.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thanks for your overview.
A lot of things resonate.
I'll ask a slightly provocative
question, just because I can.
And you touched upon it, but
I'll ask a little bit more.
So I think people have
noted that health care is
a field with a particularly
high tolerance to pain
or disorganization.
You know, just look at which
other field do people still
work 24-hour shifts, or which
other field do people actually
go to school for 15 years.
And so my question is around
tolerance to broken stuff.
And so, for example,
it's faster and easier
to actually search
trillions of documents
on the web than a
few thousand of notes
about this individual patient.
Or, we are probably more
accurate in predicting
the click on this ad
than Nigam's model
is on predicting readmission.
And so, what would it take for
physicians or administrators
or patients to say, this
is not really good enough?
Why is this such a high
tolerance to things
not being good enough?
And this is going back to your
point, great isn't good enough.
Why do people tolerate
in this industry
so much things that
are not good enough?
LLOYD B. MINOR: Well,
it's a great point.
I think it--
I don't claim to
have all the answers.
But it relates to something
I said during the talk.
And that is, why is
it, for example--
a good example of people
not tolerating chaos
would be what's happened in the
financial services industry.
You know, each of us in this
room has an ATM card probably,
and we can use it at pretty
much any ATM on the planet
to withdraw cash, perform
financial transactions.
Or we've gotten
rid of the ATM card
and we use Venmo or
something like that.
You know?
But there are a whole host
of technological solutions
that, in order for those to
work the financial services
industries had to
come together and say,
we will adopt uniform
platforms and standards.
Right?
Why?
Because I wouldn't-- would I
choose to bank with a bank that
only allowed me to use my
ATM card at their machines?
And then when I'm traveling,
you know, I can't-- no.
So there was this imperative
generated, I think,
by consumers and embraced then
by business leaders that-- no.
We have to make this
interoperable, interchangeable.
So why not in health care?
I think partly is the attitudes
that many individuals have
had about health care as being
somewhat their responsibility
but also not so much.
Not in the way that each
of us, I think, accepts
that our finances are
our responsibility.
Again, the thought
that, well, if I
get sick I'll go the doctor,
I'll take a medicine,
I'll be better.
And then that has been added
to by the traditional attitudes
in the profession which
have not engaged health care
consumers in the ways
that, for example,
something like the
financial services industry
has always known it needs to
engage its consumer base more
of.
And I'm not saying we should
become like financial services.
But it's a combination of
the inherent attitudes of--
or the previously dominant
attitudes of both consumers
and of the businesses associated
with delivering health care,
and not having those
converge on a model which
really puts the
patient first, but also
puts more responsibility
and accountability on both
the health care consumer
and the provider
to maintain health and
not just treat disease.
GREG MOORE: Thank you.
And we'll just do one
last question here.
LLOYD B. MINOR: Sure.
GREG MOORE: And
finish up with that.
In just the top
part, "how do you
see machine learning applying
to precision health use cases?"
That is, how do we take vast
quantities of information
from many patients
and actually bring it
down to a single patient
using machine learning?
LLOYD B. MINOR: Sure.
Well, there are so many sources
of information about health.
Right?
And those are not being
brought together in the way
that I think they could
be brought together.
We talked before about--
at least in the past there
have been very few incentives
for health care systems
to make their data readily
interoperable.
I mean, in an example I
told you about an ATM card.
Still, if I want to
get my medical records
from my primary care doctor
in Palo Alto to someone else,
I'm still taking them
either as printed copies
or through a fax--
fax machine.
Where else do you see
fax machines today
other than in health care?
Do you have fax machines
in your offices here?
Of course not.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, maybe you do.
OK.
I bet you don't
use them very much.
So, you know, we have to be
able to bring the data together,
aggregate the data.
And increasingly though, as
wearables become more common,
as we can look at other sources
of health-related data like
the environment, and then bring
all of those factors together,
those algorithms--
like the algorithm for
predicting readmission--
will become much more accurate
and much more comprehensive
than they are today
because they'll be based
on a broader diversity of data.
GREG MOORE: Thank you.
Please join me in
thanking Dr. Minor.
LLOYD B. MINOR:
Thank you very much.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]